Initially your body has a lot
of compensation mechanisms
to keep it at its
homeostasis-- that
temperature that it likes to
be where, your enzymes work
optimally.
So the things that your
body does to compensate
includes sweating, and
dilating your blood vessels.
But at a certain point
as the temperature rises,
you can't dilate your
blood vessels anymore
and you run out of liquid
to sweat, and at that point
your blood pressure goes down.
And then you may not get enough
blood flow to your brain.
And as you get
even hotter you're
going to have dysfunction
of the different enzymes
in your different organs.
So in addition to dehydration
related kidney failure,
you can have kidney
failure just from the heat.
As well as liver
problems and problems
with your blood clotting.
So if people have
heat exposure and they
become dizzy, light headed,
confused, slurred speech,
or weak it's very important
to seek medical attention.
The number one tip
I have is that we
should respect the desert.
We live here in the
desert which is beautiful
but it's also dangerous.
And we should take time to
be mindful of the activities
that we're planning and
what kind of heat exposure
we're going to have.